hey guys so i wanted to share with you
this video that i shot while i was at
the indy 500 and i had such a fun time
there i had actually way more fun than i
ever thought that i would to give you a
little context behind this video steak
and shake is the sponsor of the number
15 car driven by graham ray hall so when
you see me interviewing graham he's the
one that actually was driving in the
indy 500. i hope you guys enjoy the
video and if you guys get a chance go
send graeme ray hall a tweet and tell
him that he's awesome don't tell him
that i said to do it because then it
ruins the surprise hope you guys enjoy
the video i'll see you soon all right
here we go let's do this
no i am doing the indycar experience oh
two-seater ride yes and those go pretty
fast yeah we'll go fast no you don't
have to drive you'll get a ride
hopefully you get somebody really good
what if they don't
better you than me it's true
the fastest i've ever been in indy is
like 256 miles an hour
you'll probably go 180 or something like
that
okay
i guess i can't wear my hat
nope
how's it going everything's good i'm
looking forward to this this is gonna be
hopefully we don't melt
warm assistant it's really hot so this
is yeah this is tradition all right
here's the car it's official we're here
in the pit right before the race indy
500 second chig grand ray hall turn up
yeah but like
they're gonna go so fast you can't see
anything
so right now we're up in the media tower
which we have a really awesome view
actually pretty much the whole
stretch of this track
jess are you excited oh my gosh i just
put my little hat
to on